Lamar Odom has been released from rehab
after just one month a source tells ET
quote Lamar completed his program he is
doing great and can't wait to start this
new year off right what's next for you
Lamar um get back on the court are you
gonna try and play again yeah I still
got it you look like you can still play
yeah okay okay let me ask you this there
are certain websites that will follow
you around and put up pictures and post
up which we understand is not always
true how do you deal with that and
handle that I mean Inga stuff especially
if so much sick it's speculated only AG
people know the truth and I just keep
that close to my heart ET got the first
interview with the former NBA star after
he was hospitalized in 2015 he then gave
the doctors this new interview about his
near-death experience just before
entering treatment for drug and
substance abuse in December I didn't
know until and so Khloe had told me that
I was in a coma I couldn't I couldn't
even speak at the top I couldn't talk
you know gonna come up over my mouth I
was scared
you
you